all right I know many of you have been
anxiously waiting for the clips from the
Herschel Walker debate and the clips
from the Marjorie Taylor green debate
let's get right into it finally finally
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker agreed to do a debate
with the incumbent Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock now Herschel Walker
humiliated himself during this debate
not only with unintelligible word salads
but also by pulling out a fake police
badge in a way that is historic Saturday
Night Live can't even do anything with
it because how do you make a parody of
something that looks like a parody but
also Raphael Warnock didn't do
particularly well he didn't come across
as particularly passionate he didn't
come across as particularly prepared and
he refused presumably deciding that he
was not actually going to destroy Walker
for his incredible hypocrisies and
incompetence and maybe he thought it
would look better to play it a little
more polite I don't know and we will
talk about it here is the incredible
moment in which Raphael Warnock pointed
out that Herschel Walker has pretended
to be a police officer and Herschel
Walker pulls out a fake badge and then
is admonished by the uh debate moderator
almost like he's a little kid
one thing I have not done I've never
pretended to be a police officer
and and
for I've never threatened a shootout
with the police and now I have to
respond to that we are moving on
gentlemen respond to that and you know
what's so funny I am with minute police
officers so he pulled out a badge there
for those of you who couldn't see and at
the same time Mr Walker Mr Walker Mr
Walker Mr Walker excuse me Mr Walker
please say a problem I need to let you
know Mr Walker you are very well aware
of the rules tonight yes and you have a
prop that is not allowed sir I ask you
to put that prop away well it's not a
problem this is real
and of course she means a prop in the
sense of the debate that they have an
item and he said I have a problem
Mr Walker excuse me sir yes you're very
well aware of the rules aren't you well
are you aware of being brought up the
truth let's talk about the truth thank
you so listen
nobody will ever actually respond like
you asked the Walker campaign to provide
proof or what there's never any
explanation as to what that is every
indication is that it's either straight
up a fake badge or what would be a real
honorary badge an honorary badge is
nothing you don't flash it and an
honorary badge has no law enforcement
meaning or authority behind it it's just
something you sometimes get if you do
like a ride along or a walk through of
some kind with police
um he also after the debate claimed that
he trained with the FBI and this I mean
it's kafka-esque the the interviewer
looks very closely at the badge so when
I mentioned the FBI you know people know
I was joking but I have trained with FBI
right I was joking but he did actually
mention with the FBI FBI you know people
know I was joking but I have trained
with FBI I have supported men and women
in blue for years this is not so this is
what you were saying I'm not this is not
something that I doctors having to do so
they lied about it so so this is this
was Johnson County Herschel Walker
that's not just one I have many of bags
that I worked with Lauren he has many
badges now I have to tell you guys all
of this stuff is meaningless like
civilians don't train with the FBI
there's not even any meaning to that
they don't have any professional
certification they can't act in any way
sometimes the FBI does What's called the
familiarization when you've got an
influential member of the public where
you like you might do an obstacle course
or something like that you go to a
shooting range it's not training at all
and the idea that it connects to
carrying a badge in any way is just
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous now
let's get into some kind of substance
even though it wasn't very substantive
the moderators asked Herschel Walker
what is one idea you have a specific
idea to reduce inflation he just gives a
word salad you've been openly critical
blaming President Biden and the
Democrats for inflation and for the
economy if elected what is one idea one
idea that you would Champion to reduce
inflation we ask you to be specific you
have 60 seconds good luck well first of
all you have to blame this
Administration and Senator or not
because within two years this inflation
has gotten worse they are cut and of
course it's gotten worse all over the
world
and it doesn't seem to have anything to
do with Raphael Warnock so energy uh
Independence they also raise taxes now
neither of those things are true
you look at oil exports and imports and
the trade balance has not changed
dramatically since Trump left there has
not been a tax increase and at the same
time the Reckless spending all our money
so he will sit here tonight and say that
he's doing a good job for us and you
asked me what is one job I would do to
help the inflation first of all we've
got to become independent of energy
independent again and the reason why
they are we're going to our enemies to
ask for gas and oil and that puts us not
just in a inflation problem but it put
us on a national security problem and I
think that's something that I think
Senator why not need to realize and he
mentioned that he grew up here in
Savannah all right so he doesn't give an
answer he doesn't that there's no actual
answer to the question then in another
completely unintelligible moment
Herschel Walker says Americans have to
get off of Government Health Care
and get on the health care that Raphael
Warnock has which is of course
government health care because if you
have an able-bodied job you're going to
have health care but everyone else have
health care is the type of health care
you're going to get and I think that is
the problem and what Senator Warner want
you to do is depend on the government
what I want you to do is get off the
government health care and get on the
health care he's got right get you a
better health care yeah a government
plan that's that's what's fascinating so
that's what I'm trying to do to make you
independent yep Herschel Walker will
make you independent on Health Care by
getting you off of Government health
care and getting you on government
health care which will make you
independent of the government it's
pretty interesting then here is Walker's
rhetoric on abortion and again when he
is asked about this incredible double
standard wherein he claims to be against
abortion but also a paid for an abortion
and urged the same woman to get a second
abortion it's all totally incoherent
regardless of who wins in November will
you accept the outcome
thank you very much gentlemen Buck over
to you thank you Tina we turn now to the
topic of abortion we're going to start
with you Mr Walker a week before this
debate a former girlfriend made public
accusation saying you paid for an
abortion and that you encouraged her to
have another in an ABC news interview
this week you said that the accusations
are quote all lies for the voters
watching tonight can you explain the
circumstances surrounding these claims
you have 60 seconds well as I said
that's a lie and you know what most
thing I put I put it in a book one thing
about my life is I've been very
transparent not like the senator he's
here things but at the same time I said
that's a lie and on abortion you I'm a
Christian I believe in life right but
you paid for the abortion and I tell
people this Georgia is a state that
respects life and I'll be a senator that
protects life and I say that was a lie
and I'm not backing down and we have
Senator Warner people that would do
anything and say anything for this seat
but I'm not gonna back down because this
back down from what see it's too
important to the Georgia people for me
to back down right now
you've been vocally pro-life supporting
a ban on abortions without exceptions
would you support a complete ban on a
national level that's not true either I
say I support uh a heartbeat bill and I
say I support the Georgia heartbeat bill
because that's the bill of the people
from Governor Kim what
that has exceptions in it I said I'm a
Christian but I'm also representing the
people of Georgia and that's who I
represent so yeah so just continuing to
say that what appears to be an obviously
true story about him paying for the
abortion and urging a second one isn't
real but he won't actually engage with
the merits of it which is this is the
mother of one of your kids right yes
okay so and you were at one point in a
relationship with her right yes are you
denying she ever got pregnant or what
like if it was actually subjected to
some questioning it would almost
certainly fall apart now two other notes
on this the moderation in this debate
was a disaster they gave easier
questions to Herschel Walker presumably
because they understood he couldn't
handle tougher questions but also
Raphael Warnock did not do well and I
wouldn't be shocked
Walker didn't fall apart partially
because Warnock didn't bring the heat
and so it wouldn't shock me for the race
to get closer after the debate rather
than actually further apart so
disappointed in Raphael warnock's
performance Walkers was of course a
total disaster
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and armchairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below